o oswaldo minda mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer um supercampeão que
neste caso de para desenhos lápis antes
que vocês perguntem
mas é claro vocês podem usar munição
muito variada e só uma coisa pode
parecer que não mas estarmos para mais
dez metros no ângulo de 45 graus
então por isso vocês não podem contar
ela conta ninguém devem usar óculos de
proteção antão de sob toda a gente o
cartola em casa e só vez não tem
desculpa para não serem responsáveis
então bola está o tempo aí eu deixo o
linck na descrição é só vocês irem lá
carrego é e vou imprimir qual é ouvir
que vocês não precisam imprimir coxa só
fiz a coisa para vocês perceberem melhor
está parte do passo a passo e tenha uma
atenção como é que vocês vão cortar os
políticos que é sempre na direção oposta
ao huoc e diques sempre fazer quando era
pequenino já o bastante então eu gosto
do frio essas coisas para evitar lesões
já estou muito feliz peça ajuda a um
adulto é de certeza que eu não sou é
importado entrar nesta nossa brincadeira
de fazer uma coisa e acho que isso é
muito engraçado
depois vocês cortaram os quatro times
bem colar 22 já usar cola quente mas
vocês podem e devem usar aquela escola
especiais para a matéria o treinamento
vai ficar muito melhor
é só usar essa cola porque é mais fácil
fazer essa tarefa
em seguida muscular eu prometo que em
cruz sobrepondo esse método certo
agora tem encurtar 4 pelo pisão maio já
curta então lá te quero
depois cortaram por cólera nestas partes
e colar
isso é para que fique tudo nivelado para
que esta base no banco tem que fazer
isso para os quatro lados
fica assim um chefe para fora e eu achei
muito bonito
então se vocês quiserem podem tirar como
eu estou a fazer o que está abaixo feita
agora para que haja uma rotação de 360
graus e vou pôr é nesta parte da tampa e
com a parte da rosca
é este o tempo não é daquelas bem
pequenininhas nem muito grande entre
média cai e você até pode usar aquelas
maior só não vai ficar assim tão bonito
o importante é que não seja dos mais
pequeninos como a masculina vai em cima
deve saber agora estou cortar os outros
points é bastante preciso propor é
sempre a mesma coisa que no 2 nem total
da ajuda ao fazer 4 a gente sempre
processo e depois que o lixo vocês vão
ajustando até ficar prefeitinho avaí
eu não podia ser é pra todos os meus
tempos vai ter algum erro é um quadrinho
é mais um momento ou número e neste caso
eu enganei me vê ser-lhe é 2 e os 4 a 2
e já viram já vai perceber que os
créditos escolares
estou fazendo agora parte do mix de
educar nessa também do cano entendeu a
atenção para que não fique cola dentro e
pela atenção também ao encaixe que estou
a fazer
nesta parte a um ponto em que fica mais
próxima e outro mais pra baixo e muito
bem aqui mas já fiz é este plano umas
três vezes em armas diferentes então vou
deixar na instituição um vídeo em que o
neusa e cola na parte do primeiro lote
com daqui para frente seja um número
irregular que os políticos vão ser dois
e não quatro
vejam que é só fazer uma translação para
ver o lugar certo para pôr é a escola
ali o pantchinho verde viu sair um crime
para fora
vocês vocês muitas vezes vão ter que
cortar alguma coisa só porque dão cinco
lixa para ficar tudo ajustado
agora é só procurar este presente pm
agora é uma para trem que fiz que é para
agarrar a arma para conseguir dar o têti
vida dela e fazer isso eu esperei uma
arma que foi usada na primeira guerra
mundial aquelas metralhadoras a cair e
nem sei como é que sabe mas eu gosto
muito destas termas henry mesmo é fazer
uma coisa do gênero que já que está roda
e tal é e plantas perenes e acho que eu
não tinha essa parte porque ajuda a
gostar do mundo ficou nets ajudará
depois vamos falar de um lápis e vão
degustar um carinho para que o caiba
livremente dentro do carro cair a arma
do fim desse modo quadrado e o console
fica melhor e mais fácil depois fazer
esta parte em que os olímpia brooklin
colapso
então eu também corta depois marcão aqui
é o lugar que eu ia mais ou menos para
vocês só vão cortar na primeira linha a
90 graus até a parte da lan que grafita
é pois vão desgastando desta maneira
já aqui como vai funcionar o sistema já
não lá 2.20 minutos só tem um lado entra
em dois pontinhos vai encaixar aquela
partida aí vocês vão tocar para dentro
vai estudar o tipo e que tal elástico se
usar um laço que é usado pelas
costureiras que é muito mais forte e
ouvir que a força de avançar vai
depender desse lastro então quanto mais
forte for melhor pra você
este é um dos mais fortes vocês podem
encontrar para vocês podem usar é lá que
ficam os escritórios mas não vai ficar
assim tão forte eu já tentei parar 15
médio não vai parar 10 como é dito nas
provas também dá pra brincar
tenha atenção como é que vão colar o
elastic que não podem ter feito naquela
corta quer ver o que é possível para
baixo
o lado que não tem o corpo para não
interferir no encaixe de veiculado é só
tornaram
já tenha sido dito ao menino de cinco
minutos atrás para ele foi se estendendo
até a noite
é eu vou deixá-lo inscrição do outro
vídeo em que nesta parte usa a escola
mas sim fita
se não tiver essa cola instantânea
instantânea e mais forte podem vê-la e é
só substituir a parte cola fita
veja aqui o sistema só falta mesmo a
levantar aqui aprender mais uma conexão
para ajudar a água só temos a rotação de
360 graus
agora precisamos dar outra lotação que
pra cima pra baixo não é 360 graus com
nélvio de mais ou menos 80 graus já é o
suficiente para ajustar os tipos de
conhecer
veja aqui como ficou o lado e vejo que a
rolha não pode ficar colada e ficar
livre cola é um sistema de maneira
bastante simples da capital e depois não
lembrar de fazer porque é intuitiva aí
pra gente fazer mas é bastante simples e
só sendo fim estava em estado se vocês
quiserem usar o canal da rocinha
inscrevam para acompanhar as coisas que
eu faço
eis um sobre a triste de um grande
abraço de tchau